big day for clark county school district
today students staff return to class
after a five-day pause as you remember
ccsd they stopped the school year
because coronavirus cases were rising
and there were staff shortages as well
our team coverage starts at bianca
holmen live from valley high school with
some reaction from the educators the
front line bianca
good morning so teachers we spoke with
well they have mixed feelings about
returning to school after a five-day
pause you can see teachers arriving here
at valley high school ready to
again serve kids in person not virtual
this is all back in person back here in
the building so again that five-day
pause ends today from administrators
covering classes or doubling up classes
each school has a different hurdle to
overcome the five-day pause was put in
place to help people recover and nurses
to catch up on coven 19 phone calls
everyone is doing double duty cleaning
their environments and trying to ensure
students social distance some educators
well they don't see the end in sight
there is a huge shortage and there is a
a major issue
with teachers
calling out legitimately calling out
being
with you know symptoms
um i think this is just something that
we're going to have to deal with over
the next
year or two i don't want to go back to
virtual learning those kids we're not
getting the academic rigor that they're
getting in the classroom
so many teachers feel the exact same way
they say in-person learning is best but
they want safety of course to be a
priority so of course parents have their
own concerns we're going to send it back
to you guys in the studio bianca holman
live local now all right bianca thank
you very much